-Chelsea, I imagine --
Look, you know,
I'm living with my wife.
It has to be so hard
to be single right now.
Or is it great being single?
-I mean,
I think for this period of time,
it's been helpful to be single
because now I know
that I'm like,
"Okay, so if I were to eve
go through this again, what kind
of partner I'd be looking for.
But I don't have any regrets
about being single.
I mean, every--
Not everyone.
But there are too many divorce
going around for me to ever have
confidence in that kind of
institution for myself.
I know that I would be
prone to divorce.
So I'm just gonna
stay out of the marriage gam
for the rest of my life...
-Yep.
-...and not ruffle any feathers.
-Is there anything romanti
about talking to anyone
in this time, knowing that
there's no physical componen
in the near future?
-Yeah. 'Cause, like,
what's the protocol?
So you get tested, but then,
don't you have to get tested
really kind of three times
within five days to find i
after you've been exposed?
So, I don't know what you do
I'm not into, like,
virtual phone sex.
Like, I'd rather just
take a Xanax and go to bed
I'm not interested
in anything like that.
-Well, that's romantic, too.
-Yeah, that's kind of romantic
That's a personal fantasy
of my own.
-Do you find romance in watching
Governor Cuomo of New York
Is that --
-It's so funny.
I'm on a press tour
about my paperback edition
and I keep getting all these
questions about Andrew Cuomo
It's like I'm doing a press tour
about him
and his press briefings.
-You should at least get him
to plug your book
during one of
his press conferences,
just to repay the favor.
-Oh, yeah.
But the press briefings
are over.
So, they just ended it.
-Oh, yeah, that's true.
Well, he'll have
to do press again.
-You're obviously not
as big of a fan as I am.
-I'm just saying,
there's gonna be a second wave
and he'll be back up there
And he might as well
have your book next to him
-Well, what I do --
You're right.
I like your suggestion,
and I'll pass it along.
What I just -- I think that, you
know, the competence, obviously,
is a huge aphrodisiac
these days.
I think we're all
completely dehydrated
from a lack of leadership.
So, him coming on the scen
in the way he did
to give clarity to a topic
that we all still
don't know enough about,
that was one thing.
But then he did it again,
you know, with police reform
He led the country.
Like, there's 20 states
following -- and hopefully
more -- following suit.
And he's gonna keep doing it
because he was listening
to the people.
And it's like, "Oh, my gosh.
It's just so seductive
to see anybody in politics
speak like that."
And I actually do think, like,
in the last couple weeks,
everybody in politics has been
standing up a little straighte
since Cuomo came on the scene.
If you see all the people
that are speaking up about Trump
that didn't for many years -
not John Bolton.
But, you know, all the others.
He's setting an example
for politicians everywhere
Because older white guys
need a reboot.
-Yeah.
I think that's very fair.
And what about Gavin Newsom,
the governor of your own state
How are you feeling about him?
-Well, he has great hair.
But, I mean...
-Yeah.
-He's not front-and-center
the way Cuomo has been.
-Gotcha, okay.
-You know, we just got
a mandatory mask wearing.
I mean, we opened up Californi
when we were in better shape -
I mean, we opened up in
California when we were
in worse shape
than when we closed it.
So, I mean, it's a hot mes
in this country right now.
So, yeah.
-It is a hot mess.
I was very happy to hear thi
because I know that you ha
sort of stopped doing stand-up
but you're gonna do a specia
for HBO Max.
And what's it like now --
One, why did you
decide to do it?
And, two, are you finding this
time to be a creative time
insofar as you can write
material without being abl
to go out and see how it plays
-Well, I think --
I did a big tour before this
right off the back of
when I was interviewing --
when you interviewed me
for my book.
I did a whole tour
where I was being interviewed.
And through that, I just started
telling stories from the book.
And I was like, "Oh, this is
a one-woman show."
I just have to take these
stories and put it
into stand-up form because
you know, they was as much funny
as there was drama or trauma
And I really wanted to mak
a stand-up show that had emotion
along with, like,
it packs a hard comedy punch
I wanted it to make people
walk away with something.
And now, I've figured out
how to do that.
So, I'm shooting it for,
yeah, HBO Max,
but I have to shoot it in COVID,
so we're figuring that out
-Yeah, well --
-Maybe I'll shoot it at th
governor's mansion in Albany
-Yeah, there you go!
-I've finally come home!
[ Both laugh ]
-It is always so lovely
to see you, Chelsea.
Hopefully next time in person.
And congrats again on the book
As I told you last year,
it's such a fun,
moving, thoughtful read.